Be sure to subscribe to Lang,
focus and click the notification button.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is polled it.
Why did English become the international
language?
That is the question that we're going to
answer today.
English is the defacto Global Lingua
Franca.
It's the language of global commerce.
It's the main language of international
diplomacy.
It's the language of air traffic control
and it's the language of the majority of
academic journals and maybe most
importantly for us,
it's the most common language on the
Internet and it's also the language that
international travelers with different
native languages used to communicate
with each other.
The very definition of a Lingua Franca,
but how did English reach this kind of
status?
Well,
it's partly because of the role of the
United States of America as a global
superpower,
but the stage was set earlier than that.
In the 16th century,
England started to establish overseas
colonies and by the end of the 18th
century,
the British Empire had grown quite
extensive with colonies and a few parts
of India and Africa in the Caribbean,
Canada,
and what was to become the United
States.
The British were not the only ones
establishing colonies of course,
much of present day Canada and the US
was part of new France,
a large area that had been colonized by
the French,
but these areas were lost to the British
during the seven years war and much of
what is now the southern and western
United States was colonized by the
Spanish,
but these areas were taken by the United
States in wars with Spain and later
Mexico.
The Dutch had also colonized an area
known as New Netherlands,
but it was lost to the British and the
late 17th century.
There were also non British immigrants
to the British colonies of North
America.
For example,
German speaking immigrants for a long
part of the USA is history.
German was at second most widely spoken
language.
It declined in use during the first
world war because of the stigma of being
associated with Germany.
So while there were numerous languages
spoken by settlers,
English became the dominant language of
the United States.
The British kept on establishing
colonies after American independence,
including much larger areas of the
Indian subcontinent and Africa,
Australia and New Zealand,
and after the first world war in the
Middle East in 1922,
the British empire covered almost a
quarter of the earth and about one fifth
of the world's population.
Some of these countries became populated
by English settlers,
and these are the countries where
English became the dominant language,
replacing many others.